president Trump's top economic expert
says the message from the threat of
another 100 billion dollars in tariffs
on Chinese goods is enough is enough
Washington and Beijing continue to play
their game of high-stakes economic
chicken tonight with China warning it
will do whatever it has to to fight back
that situation along with a lower than
expected number of jobs created in March
led to another big market sell-off today
the Dow sank 760 points before ending
the day off 572 the S&P 500 dropped 58
the Nasdaq lost 161 chief White House
correspondent John Roberts starts us off
tonight from the North Lawn good evening
John wreck it evening to you tariffs
against Chinese and US goods are still
months away from being implemented if at
all so the wild gyrations that we're
seeing on Wall Street are driven by
speculation about what might happen the
problem is no one knows what will happen
but clearly the stakes are growing
higher the proclamation from President
Trump that he's thinking about tariffs
on another hundred billion dollars in
Chinese goods took the world by surprise
including his new chief economic adviser
when the president first to tell you
that he was gonna announce there's
additional potential hundred billion
dollars in tears
[Music]
last evening the threat was in response
to China targeting 50 billion dollars in
US goods for possible tariffs an
escalating game of brinksmanship that
President Trump insists won't tip into
an all-out trade war we've already lost
a trade war we don't have a trade war
we've lost the trade war because for
many years whether its splinting or the
bushes or obama all of our presidents
before have for some reason they just it
just got worse and worse the White House
has been carefully downplaying the
notion of a looming trade war but
Treasury secretary Stephen minuchin said
the stock market into a nosedive this
afternoon when he said on business
channels CNBC that a trade war is a
possibility China has not yet announced
more retaliatory tariffs in response to
the latest threat but a spokesman for
the Commerce Ministry sent this warning
woman was younger we do not want to
fight but we are not afraid to fight a
trade war China will fight back for sure
China will respond in a new and
comprehensive way President Trump
insists that China needs the u.s. more
than the US needs China China depends on
a robust export market to sustain its
spectacular economic performance
China's debt has also soared to more
than 300 percent of GDP because of a
lending binge to fuel growth China is
trying to vacuum up as much technology
as possible to transform its economy
anything to slow the pace of Chinese
exports could have a profound effect on
China's long-term plans the White House
is enlisting help to put the economic
squeeze on Beijing just give us another
24-48 hours you're gonna see what I call
a trade Coalition of the Willing
to change and get China back into the
world by abiding by the laws
president Trump acknowledged until that
happens there could be a rocky road
ahead for the stock market I'm not
saying there won't be a little pain but
the markets gone up 40% 42% so we may
take a hit and you know what ultimately
we're going to be much stronger for it
but it's something we had to do
President Trump keeps some pain on
Russia today the White House announcing
sanctions against seven Russian
oligarchs 12 companies they own as
17 senior Russian government officials a
state-owned weapons trading company and
a bank it owns the White House saying
it's taking action against Russia's
malign activities this is in response to
the cat's a law that was signed that
Congress passed and was signed by the
president the administration is holding
Russia accountable the actions brought a
stern response from the Russian embassy
in Washington and a statement saying
Washington has delivered yet another
blow on the Russian US relations now the
sanctions cover captains of Russian
business who refused to play to
Washington scenario but a White House
that has suddenly taken a much sharper
approach to Russia than it did for the
past 15 months said the ball is in
Russia's court we would like to see is
the totality of the Russian behavior
change and we want to continue having
conversations and work forward to
building a better relationship on China
and trade the chief economic advisor
Larry Kudlow told Fox News that the
central issue here is technology and
preventing China from stealing America's
technological futures he also said that
the White House may underscore may
provide the Chinese with a list of
suggestions they'd like to see come out
of negotiations in order to avoid a
tariff war
Brett John Roberts live on the North
Lawn John thank you